this protester calls himself boots we've
hidden his face and obscured his voice
to protect his identity he's one of the
millions of Hongkongers taking to the
streets many people here are very
facemask people are hiding their
identities they fear that the government
will press departure
what started as a protest against an
extradition bill has become the most
serious challenge to the Communist
Party's Authority since the Tiananmen
Square protests three decades as the
demonstrations enter a third month
neither the government nor the
protesters is willing to back down
police fired tear gas rubber bullets
left all this time to hit the Podesta
but it's not enough to deter the
demonstrators so what happens now this
is a real nightmare for the communist
government in Beijing they can either
crush Hong Kong or they can tolerate
being defied in a way that undermines
everything about their whole structure
of government they have no good choices
[Music]
Hong Kong is one of the most important
financial centers in the world and it
has a unique status it's a city in China
but it's not entirely Chinese it has its
own currency its own passport its own
legal system there's even a boundary
between Hong Kong and the rest of China
and you need a permit to cross it this
is all down to its history in 1842 Hong
Kong was ceded by the Chinese to the
British after the First Opium War but in
1997 Britain gave it back to China Hong
Kong people are to run Hong Kong with
one important condition for 50 years
Hong Kong was to be governed under what
is known as one country two systems' the
chief executive who runs Hong Kong would
be appointed by a pro Chinese committee
but the city was guaranteed a high
degree of autonomy with its own
government legal system and economic
independence until 2047 over the past
decade those rights have been eroded
further democracy promised as part of
the handover aggrieved has yet to be
granted by China Emily Lau was a Hong
Kong politician for 25 years today she
still campaigns for democracy things
have deteriorated fast particularly
since President Xi Jinping came to power
so people are very concerned we want
freedoms we warn personal safety we won
the rule of North China's grip has got
ever tighter in 2012 the government
tried to install a patriotic Pro Chinese
educational system then five hong kong
booksellers who sold material banned in
mainland china disappeared in 2016
pro-democracy opposition leaders were
thrown out of Hong Kong's Parliament for
insulting China when swearing their
oaths and then in February this year the
government introduced a bill which would
have allowed extradition to the mainland
very few people in Hong Kong imagine
there's going to be full-on
western-style democracy but they are
very angry about the way that what they
believed they were promised was
something much more accountable where
you'd have something close to universal
suffrage the basic social contract
between the people of Hong Kong and
their government is breaking down all
this is fueling the protesters anger the
invisible hand from China are getting
more visible they are putting more
controls on Hong Kong's autonomy bakra
see Hong Kong is not China
people will say to you we know the 2047
is coming one day but we don't want it
to happen now as the protests get larger
and more violent the chance of China
intervening increases Beijing has made
thinly veiled threats to send in its
military forces the People's Liberation
Army while border teeth
dilator turn park jong-hong dollar a few
weeks ago nobody seriously thought we
could see another talent square in Hong
Kong now you can't rule it out in 1989 a
student demonstration in Beijing ended
in massacre hundreds maybe thousands
were shot dead for the Chinese
government the Hong Kong demonstrators
are defying the authority of a communist
leadership that cannot tolerate defiance
for President Xi Jinping his kind of
north and south is East and West is the
absolute authority and total control of
the Chinese Communist Party and anything
that threatens that must be crushed they
afraid that it could be very infectious
and he don't want to see such marches in
the other parts of mainland China
another fear is some protesters demand
for full independence but military
intervention would be a very risky
strategy for Beijing Hong Kong for all
its words is still a very rich world
financial center to roll troops into
that kind of a financial center would be
an economic catastrophe in 1993 Hong
Kong's GDP accounted for more than a
quarter of mainland China's today
China's remarkable rise means that Hong
Kong's economic output makes up less
than 3% of the main elements but Hong
Kong remains important for China
multinationals use it as a launchpad to
the mainland and it gives Chinese
companies access to the rest of the
world some we are very special we are a
window for China to look to the outside
world as an international city it was
all our connections it's very valuable
to China so how the turmoil is resolved
matters to more than just the people of
Hong Kong the government there said you
the People's Liberation Army may be
deployed but if that's the case the game
is over if China uses lethal force then
in economic crash there's 85,000
American expatriates in Hong Kong now
you'd see them fleeing for the airport
this all comes at a time when China and
America are waging a trade and
technology war bloodshed on Hong Kong
streets would make relations deteriorate
even further Beijing is now blaming
outsiders for the trouble we've seen
remarkably explicit state media
commentaries telling the people of China
that these protests are not just radical
and violent that are also orchestrated
by foreign forces john 1:14 jeff and i
will surely sit watch a show would you
kindly Sangha
sure for the Chinese Communist
leadership what's happening in Hong Kong
is evidence that as China rises as one
of the world's most powerful countries
that the West is using every means
possible to divide and to frustrate
China for China the situation has become
much more than a dispute over a law it's
become an existential threat Bruce and
the other protesters are holding their
breath I'm still worried of what
happened next
it was the situation with deteriorating
very rapidly China's communist rulers
must choose between two mortal dangers
the collapse of economic stability and
prosperity or the acceptance that
protests can limit the party's absolute
power
hi i'm anna i directed this film if
you'd like to find out more about the
situation in Hong Kong and its
relationship with China click on the
link to the economist website you can
also watch our film about China's
oppression of the Muslim weekers and
don't forget to Like and subscribe to
our Channel